good morning from the sky news center
i'm naomi kerbal with a roundup of what
we're looking at on the business desk
britain's biggest farmer company
glaxosmithkline has confirmed that it's
investigating allegations it bribed
Syrian doctors to boost drug sales the
move follows an anonymous email sent
last week to managers it's investigating
the allegations and has suspended
operations with distributors grocery
sales tumbled last month in the UK as
the price war between supermarkets
intensified the British Retail
Consortium reported a three-and-a-half
percent dip in food sales however
consumer confidence fed through to non
food furniture was the best performing
category Ladbrokes has announced pre-tax
profits in the first half were down
nearly fifty percent at 27 million
pounds on the back of restructuring
costs and drowning your sorrows at your
local pub well the bad news just got
sadder new research shows that closures
have increased to 31 every week from 28
last year that's it for now all this and
more from skies Janet Janelle in the
gerkin and more from the team on Sky
News calm forward slash business